in excerpt from a warm day by Louise
Glick little by little days like this
will seem normal but winter was hard the
nights coming early the dawn's dark with
a gray persistent rain months of that
and then the snow like silence coming
from the sky obliterating the trees and
gardens today all that's passed us the
birds are back chattering oversees all
the snows melted the fruit trees are
covered with downing new growth a few
couples even walk in the meadow
promising whatever they promised we
stand in the Sun and the Sun heals us it
doesn't rush away it hangs above us
unmoving like an actor pleased with his
welcome mr. president mr. Provost Madam
Secretary college heads Dean's
colleagues friends family and most of
all women and men of the class of 2016
welcome to this day I know that I speak
for those of us on stage when I say that
we are proud of what you the graduating
seniors have accomplished in your four
years baccalaureate is one of the major
markers of your Yale journey and it
serves as the closing bookend to that
late summer of two thousand twelve when
you gathered in the same space for your
freshman assembly baccalaureate invites
you to pause during what is an
exhausting weekend so please take a deep
breath slowly exhale and invest yourself
in this moment I now call on the
universe to chaplain
my sisters and my brothers I invite you
to join me in the spirit of prayer
almighty and loving God you are the one
who gives us this day in all our days in
the majesty of this life moment we your
beloved children of different colors
Creed's generations stories and tongues
are gathered in this place as one human
family united in jubilant celebration we
are filled with gratitude for our
families friends teachers and guides
their arms have sheltered us their
shoulders have boosted us and today
their hearts sore for us eternal God it
is you who calls us to our full humanity
as we celebrate our accomplishments we
are humbled and overwhelmed by what lies
ahead let us continue to caress the
beauty of your creation and may our
souls no true delight as we awaken to
the Wonder and mystery of our own
unfolding lives through the unity of
mind and spirit hold us ever close as we
seek to live in your world wisely in the
steadfast pursuit of your light and your
truth for this we say amen
oh that which pervades earth sky and
heaven which is worthy of worship that
has no beginning that which is the light
of wisdom and truth let us meditate on
the radiance of that divinity may that
brilliance help inspire and illuminate
our minds that one which represents
water light and is the quintessence in
all things may that almighty spirit
pervading the earth atmosphere and
heaven bless us with enlightenment
send forth your light and your truth
they will lead me they will bring me to
your holy mountain to your dwelling
place that I may come to the altar of
God God might delight my joy that I may
praise you with the harp oh god my god
you are the light of the world a city
built on a hill cannot be hid no one
after lighting a lamp puts it under the
bushel basket but on the lamp stand and
it gives light to all in the house in
the same way let your light shine before
others so that they may see your good
works and give glory to your God in
heaven
God is the light of the heavens and
earth the likeness of his light is that
of a niche in which there is a lamp the
lamp is in a glass the glass is as it
were a brilliant star lit from a blessed
tree an olive tree neither of the East
nor of the West whose oil seems to glow
even though no fire has touched it light
upon light God guides whom He wills to
his light God makes parables for
humanity and God has knowledge of
everything
you
on this occasion it is customary for the
present to deliver a baccalaureate
address and for the Dean of Yale College
to offer a few readings I begin with the
selection from Mary Oliver's the summer
day here the speaker is meandering in a
meadow when she's overcome by moment not
all that different from the one we are
in right now I don't know exactly what a
prayer is I do know how to pay attention
how to fall down into the grass had an
eel in the grass how to be idle and
blessed how to stroll through the fields
which is what I have been doing all day
tell me what else should I have done
doesn't everything diet last and too
soon tell me what is it you plan to do
with your one wild and precious life you
may have asked some of these same
questions yourself this year you may
have asked my time at Yale is coming to
a close have I done enough or maybe my
time at Yale is coming to a close what
do I do next these are big questions
perhaps too big to answer today so let's
reframe them for this moment and narrow
their scope what are you going to do
today what is your plan for this wild
and precious day on this day of endings
and beginnings let me suggest an answer
to these questions by daring to think
about the redemptive power of love on
jun 2015 67 a satellite orbiting the
Earth helped usher in the dawn of a new
era that evening 400 million people in
25 countries washed a global live
telecast the BBC asked the Beatles to
write a song as part of the United
Kingdom's contribution to the show the
result was a song by john lennon about
the tension between human ego and
frailty and the one thing
that could mediate it there's nothing
you can do that can't be done hung
nothing you can sing that can't be song
nothing you can say but you can learn
how to play the game it's easy
I started that way too high um
all you need is love appears later on
this side of the Atlantic New Haven was
on the verge of being torn apart by
riots as political radicals from across
the country came to the city to protest
the imprisonment of Black Panther Bobby
Seale John Hersey the novelist and
outgoing master of Pearson college
captured this moment in his book a
letter to alumni in this letter he
recounted the tension on this campus and
throughout the nation looking back at
her seas observations reminds us of two
things one the past and present are
often more like than we want to admit
and too daring to love is difficult and
it demands a constant commitment what's
the use of a degree to a man who has a
bag of gravel for heart what's the use
of a life to a man whose inner
temperature is 0 Y students ask can't
universities offer more courses that
open windows to feeling more film more
music more writing more art or
photography or doing more helping a more
pressing question for our universities
which they had better start at least
thinking about why is this country so
open to one set of emotions and their
expression rage hatred scorn put-downs
with decoration vicious criticism
character killing and so suspicious of
so hostile to another love kindness
generosity forgiveness trust praise
encouragement somewhere on campus radio
was playing nothing you can make that
can't be made no one you can save that
can't be saying nothing you can do but
you can learn how to be you in time it's
easy
all you need is love a handful of years
before the Beatles song debuted and a
full six years before her see lamented
the anger and blindness that were
leading our country away from love and
caring and forgiveness and trust critic
James Baldwin collaborated with
photographer richard avedon on an essay
titled nothing personal Baldwin who had
just published the fire next time was at
the height of his rhetorical powers and
used his talents to articulate a fierce
love for Humanity and the hope that we
would fight our way toward Redemption it
is necessary while in darkness to know
that there is a light somewhere to know
that in oneself waiting to be found
there is a light what the light reveals
is danger and what it demands is faith
pretend for example that you were born
in Chicago and have never had the
remotest desire to visit hong kong which
is only a name on a map for you pretend
that some convulsion sometimes called
accident throws you into connection with
the man or a woman who lives in hong
kong and that you fall in love hong kong
will immediately cease to be a name and
will become the center of your life and
you may never know how many people live
in Hong Kong but you will know that one
man or one woman lives there without
whom you cannot live and this is how our
lives are changed and this is how we are
redeemed I have slept on rooftops and in
basements and subways have been cold and
hungry all my life have felt that no
firewood ever warm me and no arms would
ever hold me I have been as the song
says buked and scorned and I know that I
always will be but my god in that
darkness which was a lot of my ancestors
and my own state what a mighty fire
burned in that darkness a living soul
moved and refused to die we really
emptied oceans with a home
made spoon and tore down mountains with
our hands and if love was in Hong Kong
we learned how to swim all you need is
love all you need is love all you need
is love love love is all you need moving
much closer to our present an urgent day
I turned to the wisdom of Bryan
Stevenson attorney and human rights
activist Stevenson's book just mercy is
a recollection of his efforts to fight
against mass incarceration for me the
book is also a meditation on the human
need to offer love especially in those
moments when doing so feels impossible
we are all implicated when we allow
other people to be mistreated in absence
of compassion can corrupt the decency of
a community a state a nation fear and
anger can make us vindictive and abusive
unjust and unfair until we all suffer
from the absence of mercy and we condemn
ourselves as much as we victimize others
I believe it's necessary to recognize
that we all need mercy we all need
justice and perhaps we all need some
measure of unmerited grace women and men
of the class of 2016 on this wild and
precious day leave this place knowing
that you are equipped to ask challenging
questions but you are prepared to listen
too difficult answers and that you have
everything you need to do the hard work
to navigate the unpredictable terrain
between the two as you do this work you
will spread your light and your truth to
a world that is in desperate need of
both we the librarians the professor's
the custodians the dining hall staff the
coaches the lecturers the groundskeepers
the counselors and the administration
administrators we have done all that we
can for you
the rest my friends is up to you one
last thought as the horizon overtakes
the tops of these Ivy towers just
remember love is all you need love is
all you need love is all you need love
is all you need love is all you need
thank you and congratulations
colleagues friends families graduating
seniors I'm not going to sing but it is
a pleasure for me to greet you today and
offer a few words on everyone's favorite
weekend of the year so I've noted over
the last few years a delightful yell
tradition and I'm hoping you can help me
carry it out today part 1 let me ask all
the families and friends here today to
rise and recognize the outstanding and
graduating members of the class of 2016
and now part two but I asked the class
of 2016 to consider all those who have
supported your arrival at this milestone
and please rise and recognize them
thank you so graduating seniors like the
other seniors in Yale College before you
most of you have experienced this here
certain freedoms relative to the prior
three years freedom from distribution
requirements freedom to explore a
particular topic in your major freedom
from the demands of leadership positions
in student organizations perhaps the
freedom to enjoy more fully the breadth
and depth of the friendships you have
made at Yale after monday of course
you'll experience as well the freedom
that comes with moving on which is
really the freedom to decide how you're
going to put your Yale education to work
in the world I hope your you are
exhilarated about the choices ahead so I
expect that most of you face them with
some anxiety as well and in any case as
the fates would have it you must now
leave behind the Yale College community
and choose other communities to join
just as you once chose this one when you
arrived here you entered a community
founded well over three centuries ago
does not take much of a historian to
understand that over such a long period
of time vast changes have taken place
place both at Yale and in the society in
which yell is embedded very few of the
important changes in yells history were
easy to navigate or even to perceive
clearly while they were taking place
however inevitable or obvious they may
seem to us now we generally converge far
more in our perspectives on issues of
the past especially the distant past
than we do in our perspectives on those
of the present this will be true of any
community you decide to join in the
future particularly any as closely
knitted and highly engaged as yells as
you consider your move from Gale I want
to focus today on three responsibilities
that I believe members of a community
must share if they wish to strengthen
their interconnections and provide for
the common good first we must be
prepared to speak fully our own minds
second we must be willing to listen
carefully to what others say of their
own minds and third we must search for
common ground that provides us a basis
for moving forward no one of these
obligations it seems to me can
successfully be fulfilled without
attending to the other two as I consider
each in turn I want to shift our focus
though at least for the moment away from
talk about rights having the right to
say or do things is a very different
matter from deciding what it would be
wise and best to say or do so I'd like
to consider something that lies beyond
the bare assertion of a right and
something and that something is the hard
work it takes to be a vital and active
member of a community the first shared
obligation of community citizenship
sounds straightforward that we have the
shared responsibility especially on
matters of importance to the entire
community to speak fully our own minds
but what does it mean to speak fully
does it mean to speak at greatest length
or in the loudest voice what does it
mean something more like speaking with
the care and the intent to move a
community toward a better and deeper
understanding of a matter at hand I
proposed you that the strongest and most
effective advocates of a position resist
the temptation to demonize or mock
opponents to enflame their friends or to
simplify complex matters without
surrendering their convictions they look
instead to expand our sensibilities and
awareness to consider and respect
opposing concerns and to present us with
new options for how we might move
forward together our faith in the
progress of the Yale community or any
community would join absolutely depends
on our mutual commitment to just these
practices however much we might differ
in our perspectives or experiences over
my years at Yale I've invariably
encountered many individuals who
represented quite different views but
who approached me with considered
thorough and broadly informed reasons to
support a strongly held position and
what about not just speaking fully but
also speaking one's own mind the courage
to speak your own mind cannot be limited
to joining a group of like-minded people
or supporting a particular party
position or liking an online comment in
the heat of battle or natural impulses
to circle the wagons close ranks and
show party loyalty but it can sometimes
take significantly more courage to
express a disagreement or a concern
among those we take to be our friends
than to disagree with those we take to
be our opponents so as you go out in the
world joining and creating communities
it can also be immensely difficult to
hear in full a differing view which
brings me to the second shared
obligation of members of a community the
responsibility to listen to listen fully
to what others are saying especially
when we find their views disturbing or
irrelevant to our own concerns we know
very much from research in social
psychology which is my field and you
know from your own lives that people are
powerfully subject to confirmation bias
we gravitate strongly toward like-minded
people
and we attend to sources of information
that resonate with our existing beliefs
social media II social media only served
to reinforce these psychological
tendencies people I've increasingly
narrowed their listening two channels
expressing and reading reinforcing
opinions they already hold beyond even
that it takes unusual willpower and
commitment to listen fully not only for
what someone is saying but for why
you're she is saying it to understand
the personal experience that motivates
interest as well as the intellectual
experience that informs argument so let
me personalize the dynamic I've been
describing just a bit I have a close
friend let's call him Alan Alan's view
of the world differs from my own view as
much as any friend that I have Alan is
opposed to considering race ethnicity or
economic class in any way when admitting
students to yell Alan does not think the
law should establish a minimum wage Alan
believes in a free society you should
have the right to sell your kidney or
for that matter the right to sell your
vote these opinions I find strange even
in some cases simply wrong and yet we're
friends we talk a lot we listen
carefully neither of us dismisses the
other suggestions or passes judgment on
motivations generally we don't succeed
in changing each other's beliefs though
sometimes we do but we both leave our
discussions and yes even our most
difficult arguments and there have been
many better informed and more able to
appreciate a divergent perspective we
are also able to value and sustain our
friendship while differing sometimes
sharply in our views I'm certain that
yell
done its usual excellent job in
educating each and every one of you but
I'm equally certain that with time and
change some of the ideas that will stick
with you most are ones you found hardest
to grasp or accept the first time you
heard them from a fellow student just as
important as anything that you have
learned in a seminar or in a lab I hope
that Yale has been a place that
encourage you to find friendships like
mine and Alan's with individuals whose
ideas maybe in some critical way opposed
to your own in older academic writings
you can find reference to something
called the principle of charity and
interpretation this is the principle of
treating an opposing view in what you
take to be its strongest and most viable
form something you can only achieve by
actively seeking out and listening
carefully to its ablest proponent doing
so increases your capacity to enter into
a productive dialogue first because it
will strengthen your grasp of what
actually differentiates your own view
and second because it will open you to
the real possibility of changing your
mind I think of the student who once
told her professor that this teacher had
finally persuaded her of a point about
which they had disputed you win said the
student no said the professor you win
you have learned one of the most
difficult things how to change your mind
so let me close by saying something that
I know just scratches the surface of the
third shared obligation of citizenship
in any community worthy of the name the
responsibility to seek common ground for
the sake of the community as a whole you
have just as we all have much to learn
from others in every community you join
yet you will predictably confront
tension between what you perceive to be
your own individual or
group interests and what you perceive to
be the common ground you share with
others you will be tempted to think that
the search for common ground is simply
equivalent to a demand that you concede
ground your own ground at that not to
pursue common ground however is fatal to
a community and to progress I hope you
share my anxiety about the degree to
which we are seeing this tendency coming
to the fore nationally and
internationally to find common ground
does not mean surrendering principles
but it does mean seeking creative
compromise to find common ground we must
give up calls to judgments and demands
for instantaneous results well instead
undertaking the hard painstaking
sometimes plotting task of designing and
implementing workable solutions in which
all members of the community have a
stake finding common ground will never
be free of confrontation but it will
never stay stuck in confrontation it
will look for the best of others not
imagine the worst I hope that is a
member of the elk community you have
learned to speak fully listened
intensely and seek common ground in many
aspects of your life these skills will
serve you well in your coming ventures
especially as you carry out our
University's mission which is to improve
the world today and for future
generations so let me ask the members of
the class of 2016 to rise
as you go out as you go out onto a world
that is all before you hand in hand with
wandering steps and slow bring to that
world all that you're yell education has
given you the ability to appreciate
complexity even while seeking simplicity
to engage critically even while
listening respectfully and to recognize
your responsibilities even while finding
pleasure in their new communities we are
delighted to salute your accomplishments
and we are proud of your achievements
remember to give thanks for all that has
brought you to this day and go forth
from this place with grateful hearts
paying back the gifts you have received
here by using your minds your voices and
your hands to strengthen your new
communities and your world
congratulations class of 2016
I've asked to announce oh the
president's reception will be held in
Commons immediately following this
ceremony let us pray may God bless you
and keep you may the eternal show you
favor and be gracious to you may the
Holy One cause light to shine upon you
and grant you peace and let us say amen
you